[Música]
en Colombia la principal disidencia de
la antigua guerrilla de las FARC anunció
que la mesa de negociación con el
gobierno de Gustavo Petro se instalará
el 16 de mayo el grupo armado pidió a la
guerrilla del ejército de liberación
nacional que ponga fin al conflicto con
El Ejecutivo tenemos análisis
dos nuevos tiroteos masivos acudieron a
Estados Unidos este fin de semana uno en
Alabama y otro en Kentucky los hechos
dejaron seis víctimas mortales y decenas
de heridos ya son más de 160 tiroteos
masivos solo en 2023
los sindicatos franceses anunciaron
nuevas jornadas de huelga luego de que
el presidente Manuel promulgará su
polémica reforma al sistema de pensiones
este lunes en la noche hora de París se
espera un pronunciamiento del mandatario
al respecto
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano y del mundo soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos damos inicio en Colombia
donde el Estado Mayor central la
principal disidencia de las antiguas
FARC anunció que la mesa de diálogo con
el gobierno será instalada el próximo 16
de mayo además pidieron al eln que ponga
fin a los enfrentamientos con el estado
para analizar esta información
conversamos previamente con Néstor
Rosalía director ejecutivo del centro de
estudios en seguridad y paz en Colombia
que nos dijo si Pese a que falta una
parte importante de la implementación
del proceso de la Habana es conveniente
iniciar diálogos con otras
organizaciones y cómo se ve que las
disidencias de las FARC le pidan a la
guerrilla del eln que ponga fin a los
enfrentamientos con el estado
hay un gran reto porque por ejemplo con
las farnos implementado todo a las
víctimas no se les ha reparado y faltan
muchas cosas por hacer el estado y la
institucionalidad colombiana se ha
quedado corta frente al tema de la
implementación Y no solo con las Farc
sino históricamente en otros procesos de
paz es un mensaje porque ellos lo que
quieren es Buscar un espacio político
para que también puedan entrar dentro de
un modelo de negociación de proceso de
paz y que el gobierno no los deje en ese
espacio de sometimiento a la justicia
porque esta disidencia no es seguro que
vaya a entrar un proceso de negociación
por el contrario desde la oposición y
muchas bancadas dentro del Congreso
están pidiéndole a Petro que no los deje
entrar a un proceso de paz sino que los
dejen sometimiento a la justicia
seguimos en Colombia porque la
asociación madres de falsos positivos
madres de jóvenes civiles que el estado
hizo pasar por bajas en combate
conmemoraron 15 años de lucha contra la
impunidad según la jurisdicción especial
para la paz nacida de los acuerdos de La
Habana al menos seis mil cuatrocientos
dos jóvenes inocentes fueron ejecutados
extrajudicialmente
vamos a Estados Unidos donde este fin de
semana se saldó con otros dos tiroteos
masivos uno en Alabama y otro en
Kentucky que ya había sido escenario a
principios de semana de otro ataque
armado ambos tiroteos terminaron con
múltiples víctimas mortales y heridos y
se suman a una larga lista de más de 160
balaceras masivas solo en lo corrido de
2023 Marta Moya tiene más detalles
dos nuevos tiroteos masivos que
reafirman la problemática de la
violencia Armada en Estados Unidos en la
noche del sábado la ciudad de Louisville
en el estado de Kentucky volvió a ser
escenario de un nuevo tiroteo en un
parque público que dejó dos muertos y
cuatro personas heridas cinco días antes
en la misma urbe otro ataque armado en
un banco dejó cinco muertos y cuatro
heridos
esta ha sido una semana
indescriptiblemente Trágica para nuestra
ciudad el lunes perdimos a cinco de
nuestros conciudadanos en un horrible
acto de violencia Armada en un lugar de
trabajo
y ahora cinco días después estamos en
otra escena de un acto imprudente de
violencia Armada
Esta no es nuestra ciudad Esto no es lo
que somos Esto no es lo que queremos ser
también el sábado otro tiroteo en el
pueblo de David Alabama la fiesta de
cumpleaños de un adolescente culminó con
cuatro muertos más y una veintena de
personas heridas Aunque todavía se
desconoce el móvil del ataque
les pido que mantengan a nuestra
comunidad en sus oraciones les pido que
mantengan a mi departamento de policía
en sus oraciones Y también les pido a
cada uno de ustedes que no dejen que
este momento defina lo que piensan sobre
la ciudad de David y nuestras buenas
personas
los recientes tiroteos masivos se suman
a los más de 160 ataques de este tipo
registrados en lo corrido del año según
el archivo del portal gambaiolens un
escenario complejo que se enmarca en el
debate del porte de armas que los
demócratas quieren regular y una parte
de los republicanos siguen reivindicando
como un derecho constitucional todo ello
mientras se van engranando las campañas
electorales de Cara a las presidenciales
de 2024 vamos ahora con noticias de la
guerra en Ucrania porque sobre el
terreno continúa la batalla por el
control de bajo mundo en esta ciudad
estratégica del este del país las
fuerzas ucranianas se aferran a pesar de
la ofensiva rusa un equipo de nuestra
cadena hermana fue al frente de batalla
y acompañó a los soldados ucranianos
veamos
es un francotirador escondido en un
edificio de bacmut solo lo acompaña su
arma
el objetivo ruso está 1,2 km de
distancia
se prepara para otra misión está a punto
de salir con sus hombres a patrullar la
zona en una operación de reconocimiento
avanzan hacia donde se escuchan las
explosiones de los proyectiles la
situación se ha vuelto más tensa en los
últimos días el centro de bacmut es
ahora una ciudad fantasma
su misión es delicada y peligrosa el
pelotón de reconocimiento debe rastrear
objetivos rusos para informar a las
tropas ucranianas que están más atrás el
panorama es confuso
refugiado unas horas después de su
operación el ex legionario que pasó
cinco años en Francia explica la
situación militar Hablamos
ahora mismo diría que al menos el 50% de
la ciudad está tomada por los rusos
su avance continúa
el consumidor
la situación es muy dura muy complicada
los ataques y asaltos rusos continúan
constantemente continúan los ataques los
disparos de todos los calibres
pero las fuerzas ucranianas siguen
resistiendo nuestro equipo pudo visitar
una de sus posiciones de artillería A
las afueras de backmuto Caminando un
kilómetro por rutas alternas para llegar
aquí y evitando espacios abiertos ambos
bandos disparan proyectiles
alguna de nuestras fuerzas siguen en el
centro de la ciudad
hemos venido a reconquistar nuestra
tierra no entregarnos
están esperando las coordenadas de un
nuevo objetivo después de intercambiar
disparos todo el día siguen atentos para
la contraofensiva desde hace semanas y
esperan que los suministros de armas y
equipos sean suficientes
el presidente francés Emanuel
mccompromulgó su polémica reforma de las
pensiones a pesar de la oposición civil
que se manifestó multitudinariamente en
reiteradas ocasiones encontrado el
proyecto en respuesta a los sindicatos
están organizando nuevas huelgas para
expresar su descontento una muestra de
aquel conflicto continuará
1200 manifestantes tomaron las calles de
rehén
para ellos la firma de la ley de reforma
de las pensiones No cambia nada no nos
rendiremos porque aunque el movimiento
sea cada vez más pequeño es importante
no Rendirse y demostrar que seguimos
aquí
es casi el fin del mundo de macron lo
que significa que no va a hacer nada en
los próximos cuatro años va a fracasar
siempre que intente hacer algo entonces
qué es lo siguiente para el movimiento
los sindicatos ferroviarios ya han
planeado una huelga para el próximo
jueves tenemos que desempeñar nuestro
papel pasar a la acción y ser receptivos
no esperar al día del trabajo Seremos
una de las locomotoras el sindicato cgt
ha anunciado dos fechas importantes para
las huelgas el jueves 20 de abril y el
Viernes 28 de abril antes de las masivas
protestas por el día del trabajador el
primero de mayo un tono muy diferente en
la reunión del Consejo Nacional del
partido de macrón
Los partidarios del presidente quieren
pasar página rápidamente a la reforma de
las pensiones
ahora tenemos que avanzar y seguir
centrándonos en el empleo que es
realmente esencial
todavía tenemos cuatro años por delante
con macron como presidente tenemos que
aprovechar el periodo para reavivar el
diálogo en su discurso de clausura la
primera ministra confirmó su
determinación de acelerar su agenda de
reformas para garantizar el servicio de
salud para todos para el poder
adquisitivo de los ciudadanos para
luchar contra el cambio climático para
la seguridad de nuestras calles para la
igualdad de género los ciudadanos
franceses no esperan una respuesta de la
derecha o de la izquierda sino que
quieren respuestas rápidas
macron pronunciará un discurso en
horario de Máximo audiencia El lunes por
la noche en lo que según el palacio del
Eliseo es una medida para aliviar las
tensiones tras tres meses de intensas
protestas contra su gobierno fin del
informativo gracias por su sintonía
[Música]